hi there steve kaufman here today i'm
going to make what i consider to be
one of my most important videos
for language learners
i'm going to talk about what i consider
to be the biggest mistake that most
language learners make
okay
this is the biggest mistake the biggest
obstacle the biggest hurdle
uh
the biggest
thing that prevents people from
succeeding and becoming fluent
whatever that means
and that mistake is that people stay
with the beginner
material for too long they stay with a
beginner book they stay with the
beginner course the beginner lesson they
never get beyond it
and it's quite unnecessary if you buy a
beginner book which i think is a good
thing to do if you embark on learning a
new language
that beginner book you can use it for a
year but you keep on going back to it
you don't try to master it you don't try
to
learn it understand it you don't have to
learn or remember the dialogues the
vocabulary the grammar rules nothing
it's just a bit of an initial guide
something that you go back to
regularly
as soon as possible you have to get away
from the artificial environment of the
beginner course the beginner textbook or
whatever your teacher has you doing in
class you have to get beyond that you
have to get into real
language
now if i look at my own experience with
czech
um you know i started i kept track of it
i started july the 23rd and i was
looking at it today and on august the
4th i started bringing in
uh
using link's quick you know bookmark
that quick import a system bringing in
articles from
czech newspapers so that's uh
you know whatever it was two weeks after
i started
fighting my way through these of course
clicking on every word saving the words
to my database reviewing them not really
understanding it
uh kind of picking my way through
maybe 30 40 percent
most unclear the structure was unclear i
kept on doing it i know i again because
we keep track of these things and like
i have uh brought in something like 161
newspaper articles i started on july the
23rd august 23rd september 23rd
um you know we're halfway or we're
getting towards october 23rd i'm two in
some months so 161 newspaper articles
i started bringing in the good shoulder
soldier schweik i think was august the
14th going by memory
and then i discovered uh radio prague on
august the 23rd i happen to look this up
because we have these records in the
system
and i've been importing to my system
uh articles from the radio station with
the transcripts which they provide
and i have imported something like 65 of
these so i've read the equivalent of two
books
in check
uh of adult authentic material intended
for native speakers do i understand at
all no
do i know all the words there no
but i know a lot of it
because now when i bring in
new texts
to my account in link i can see that
there's 20 new words it used to be 80
new words and that's just by reading and
listening because i don't expect to
understand it all even though i listen
two three four times read it two three
four times i don't understand it but it
is all helping my brain get used to
check so after two months and a bit i'm
actually not bad now i can read like i
ordered some books
uh i can actually show you this
you know
here whoops
yeah i ordered a bunch of books chesky
osud
deini zemi koroni
you know
in history okay i'm gonna get my way
through these the thing is you've gotta
leave now
i'll go and read those or i'll read
more than likely it's more those are
more for the future i've still got to
read with the help of link
uh but i'll get to those
and yet still i will still go back to
the beginner book because there's all
kinds of stuff in the beginner book that
i won't learn on the first pass on the
second pass on the third pass it'll take
me the fourth or fifth pass before these
things
sink in
but a majority of people
they get the beginner book and i've got
a beginner book handy here somewhere and
they never leave it because they've
never they never feel comfortable they
don't feel they've learned everything in
the beginner book the beginner book
doesn't matter
the beginner book is like it's like that
step into the swimming pool and then you
got to start swimming
you got to start swimming so the biggest
mistake that people make
is that they stay with their beginner
material
either you know for example
i looked up i looked beginner check
courses on the internet just to see what
was there
and there are courses offered at ubc
university of british columbia here in
vancouver and they have a three-month
beginner course and a three month that's
a beginner one then they have a three
month beginner two intermediate one
course so that was six months and you're
still just beginner to intermediate one
and they do the same for dutch i mean
dutch dutch is so similar to english
and and yet six months
and you're still a beginner too or an
intermediate one no
you have to and it doesn't matter
whether you can use the language it
doesn't matter whether you can speak yet
or write yet what matters is how much
can you understand
how many words do you have how familiar
are you with the language to what extent
is the language starting to become a
part of your
the brain whatever so
the big mistake people make is they stay
with the beginner book for far too long
within a month or two or three depending
on the language you've got to get into
the real
language okay
and
to ease your way in you have now got
resources on the web with online
dictionaries and i hesitate to mention
link again because people claim that i'm
always touting linkedin that's what i
use it works for me
so there's my advice
don't stay with the beginner material
the sooner you get into the real stuff
the faster you will learn the objective
is not to fully understand something
after one or two months the objective is
to understand a lot
after 8 or 10 months and in order to do
that you've got to push yourself past
that comfort level of the beginner book
thank you for listening